buon pomeriggio
ad essere presentato come un banchiere
ecco il banchiere come andare
all'assemblea della costa crociere dire
ed eccovi lo scoglio è un periodo
abbastanza difficile provare nella city
e poi per questo mi interessava
partecipare a the da sono stato invitato
perché c'è una storia da raccontare che
la storia della finanza e qualche
maniera è un motore della società e
motore della società a lui è sempre
stato non è una cosa da sempre delle 10
miliardi a questa parte la finanza e la
società e l'economia e la società se
sono influenzati a vicenda
quindi oggi vorrei parlare in maniera
positiva di quello che vedo potrebbe
essere una rinascita una ripartenza
della finanza oggi siamo un momento
cruciale
probabilmente dai tempi premete dal
tardo medioevo in cui paradossalmente i
mercati nacquero dal popolo dalle
persone dalle persone dal mercato degli
schiavi che si organizzavano attorno al
castello dei potenti al palazzo del re
per vender loro prodotti e mercati
finanziari sono nati così le piazze del
mercato che sono nate guarda caso in
quei paesi come la germania la francia
l'italia l'inghilterra sono nate per
questa esigenza
oggi vediamo una distorsione dei mercati
è solo il primo a dirlo non solo via
fare uno solo pia oggi è augurata
un'apologia non sono qui a parlarvi
dell'utopia dei mercati o a scusarmi
anche se va di moda in questo periodo ma
per parlare maniera positiva di quello
potrebbe essere la partenza immaginiamo
che il 21 dicembre finisca questo mondo
nel riparto un altro da dove
ripartirebbe sistema finanziario
vi faccio un esempio su questa cosa
tutti penso alla finanza come qualcosa
di paludato i primi a fare short selling
c'è da fare speculazione sui mercati a
wall street
furono le femministe un gruppo di
femministe intorno a 1.830 140 fondarono
un fondo di investimento non con la sede
alle cayman e ma con la sede della wall
street e cominciano a fare short selling
per distrugge il mercato perché lo
vedevano come una rappresenta una forma
di potere maschile però in realtà i
mercati sono sempre sentito e
continueranno
mister perché continuare ad esistere gli
scambi economici finanziari
oggi vi voglio parlare di sei parole se
concetti chiave per il futuro della
finanza
userò le parole in inglese come dice
battiato il giorno della fine non ti
assemblea l'inglese ma ti servirà il
giorno dopo la fine per iniziare perché
le lingue universali della finanza
quindi la prima parola pivot la perché
ho popolo perché usato questa parola
perché tre anni fa su questo palco c'era
una persona
patti smith che è riuscito a un gruppo
di fiorentini people have the power
e c'è la famosa line ewl ed in the work
force quindi per me il vero punto di
partenza della rinascita del sistema
economico e attraverso le persone che
sono alla base so che può sembrare
un'ovvietà ma in realtà quello che sta
accadendo oggi nella tecnologia anche
della società è un punto focale quelle
compositi possono cambiare le persone
possono tornare ad avere il potere che
avevano all'epoca all'inizio del sistema
economico nel medioevo
anche qui qui dentro questa stanza fu
costruita di fatto nel periodo di
savonarola solarola sulla persona che
dopo la crisi finanziaria e la
bancarotta dei medici
l'altra banca dei medici costituì il
moto di pietà 3 aiutare le persone a
state colpite dall usura quindi anche lì
la finanza deve ripartire nel 1595
quindi poteva testo le persone il popolo
quindi quelle che siamo noi sono io
voglia eccetera che abbiamo dobbiamo
fare la fatica ora di ricostruire il
sistema c'era una slide prima sul debito
pubblico nel mondo
in realtà in america il debito pubblico
e privato e tutte le persone rappresenta
sei volte il prodotto interno lordo
americano
no per darvi un'idea da dove dobbiamo
partire e dove dobbiamo arrivare quindi
più a parola people
quindi noi riparte dalle persone e come
riparte dalle persone
riparte innanzitutto da gruppetti di
persone cloud cloud in inglese vuol dire
gruppo
di persone a firenze si direbbe a
crocchio e dalle crode crowdfounding a
proprio oggi a roma c'è un convegno che
parla di crowdfunding e parla di come le
persone possono organizzarsi partendo
dal basso faccio un esempio ho visto
recentemente a bologna un teatro per
bambini dove non raccolto soldi dai
vicini dalle persone del quartiere
vicino per finanziare il teatro è un
gruppo di ragazzi in california hanno
incominciato a finanziare da tutte le
parti a creare in rete nella rete questa
maniera di finanziare c'è uno vede a
un'iniziativa a un'idea di business la
mente in rete tutti iniziano a
finanziarlo con 150 con 200 dollari con
50 dollari diventano azionisti qualche
media di questa società e questa maniera
si crea un capitale che può essere
utilizzato per finanziare iniziativa
quindi premete il futuro della finanza
parte anche da crowdfunding due persone
che si organizzano per finanziare quello
che vogliono loro
uscendo dai binari del degli
intermediari finanziari
io sono un banchiere quindi un po mi
dispiace però in realtà è la maniera in
cui il sistema si riorganizza dal basso
come appunto nel medioevo obama fino a
approvata approvare una legge su cloud
funding nell'ultimo decreto del governo
italiano c'è riferimento a questa
iniziativa
qui sarà possibile farlo anche in italia
probabilmente eco facendo un po di
vintage
probabilmente la stessa cosa che
facevano i nostri nonni con le società
di mutuo soccorso con le cooperative di
consumo e di produzione però chiaramente
riva dall america c'è un americano però
funziona in america funziona tantissimo
e andando oltre la terza parola impact
come appunto impatto abbiamo visto prima
l'asteroide in questo caso un impatto
diverso cioè qual è l'impatto delle
nostre azioni o del presente delle
nostre delle nostre società di quello
che facciamo dei nostri finanziamenti su
cosa di solito fino a fino a poco tempo
fa calcolare l'impatto finanziario degli
investimenti
c'è una dottrina che parla che dice che
bisogna invece studiare anche l'impatto
ambientale e sociale degli investimenti
e si chiama appunto in parte investing e
si chiama la cipolla e la teoria della
triple bottom line cioè che ogni
finanziamento un investimento che
facciamo deve soddisfare un criterio di
ritorno finanziario ambientale e sociale
people planet profit vito pipolo
all'inizio perché la cosa più importante
quindi l'impact investe con la maniera
in cui finanziamenti vengono concepiti
non più nel breve o medio periodo che
questo il cambiamento importante che
deve accadere nella finanza perché fino
alla crisi 2007 siamo vissuti in una
specie di diciamo di orgia di di medio
termine di breve termine
i profitti vengono fatti per essere poi
di fatto non reinvestiti ma per essere
consumati
l'idea importante delle parti investing
diventa tutto a lungo a lungo termine
ci sono dei pazzi in america che hanno
fatto una cosa che si chiama long train
foundation e c'è un sito che credo sia
launcher foundation noto organ dove loro
studiano l'impatto delle azioni umane
sulla geologia ci farà vedere cosa
succederà fra 10.000 a 100.000 anni cioè
voi fate una fabbrica e la tele telefono
sarà l'impatto della fabbrica fra 100
minale sulle falde acquifere sul sugli
strati geologici
questo è un po estremo però per darvi
l'idea che premette dobbiamo cambiare
anche anche la diciamo la nostra il
livello temporale a cui guardiamo
impatti investe in guarda punto
all'ambiente alla società come
determinanti allo stesso livello della
finanza del investimento e anche questo
caso in america se stessa una legge e
speriamo che in italia per definire le
regole
l'altra parola e mezza
netcomm e mezzo site
perché in realtà il mercato il luogo
dove tutto questo accadrà sarà la rete
se la rete dove già ormai noi compriamo
libri paghiamo i nostri conti eccetera
eccetera
la rete cosa permette permette al nostro
piccolo crowd locale di diventare il
nostro piccolo gruppo di amici locali di
diventare globale
io posso benissimo avere un investimento
o posso fare
posso fare impresa mettendo insieme
persone ai quattro lati del mondo in
questo momento la mia figlia mi sta
seguendo da londra quindi la salute o
scusante che si stava annoiando lo
sapete fare da va in scena però questo
sarebbe stato impossibile cinque anni fa
probabilmente fra altri cinque anni sarà
possibile fare fare molte altre cose con
la rete pensate a facebook
uso questo esempio se su facebook e
accanto a mi piace o mi garba mizher
firenze ci fosse compro vendo finanziò
pensando cosa diventerebbe facebook
diventerebbe nel giro di 24 ore la più
grande e più grande fornitrice di
servizi finanziari al mondo perché
avrebbe un miliardo potenziale di
cliente se diventasse facile non c'è
forse le regole che cercano di fermare
questa crescita di libertà nella rete
quindi nel society appunto l'altra
parola seme chiave andando avanti
l'altra parola il cash quindi il futuro
del mondo chiaramente sarà cashless ora
questo non può anche leggere che avremo
sempre meno soldi in tasca ma in realtà
il futuro del contante il contante
flauto siamo a firenze dove è nato il
fiorino e in fondo il contante è
determinato nel senso che nascerà prima
o poi una moneta elettronica che sarà
vale sarà possibile utilizzarla per
scambi a livello mondiale e perché se
come questa importante del positivo
perché lo può che vederlo punto di vista
negativo e di fatto crea una forma di
controllo globale sull'economia ma ho
due esempi per spiegarvelo il primo
riguarda appunto mia figlia mia figlia
questa estate è tornata dal gelataio a 2
euro e mi fa
babbo che differenza c'è fra un euro
francese ed uno greco c'è un euro
francese vale quanto uno greco il
liberista per risponde ma parliamo le
perché in effetti aveva forse ragione
forse ma in realtà la cosa che ha fatto
l'euro che oggi tanti criticano ha
creato attraverso l'europa un'unione che
prima non c'era un senso di unità che
prima non c'era e ha ridotto l'impatto
delle crisi valutarie fondare uno
studente andavo in giro a fare l'erasmus
appunto nelle corde che andavamo eravamo
signori in spagna e peones in germania
perché devono avere le pesetas e i
marchi e clemente vivevamo sulla nostra
pelle la differenza del potere
d'acquisto
l'euro ha ridotto questo rischio europa
ha creato alti rischi ne possiamo
parlare dopo se volete ma la tela era
tutto questo rischio che ha distrutto
dell'economia in giro per il mondo
pensate all'argentina pensate alle tigri
asiatiche
ci sono tantissimi esempi in cui la
fluttuazione della valuta ha impoverito
ancora di più l'economia quindi futuro e
cash race e non solo da questo punto di
vista probabilmente bisogna che vi
definire il nostro sistema di valori
c'è una storiellina e non libro di david
gray perché si chiama debito questo
libro il parà di 5 miliardi story del
debito le cose leggo io per dormire e e
racconta questa storia in cui un re va a
mangiare in un villaggio in una bettola
non vicino reggio emilia ma non ha detto
la vera e propria e in questa beta la
meritano un pesce da mangiare quando va
a pagare lost e le chiede una cifra
esorbitante tipo sette volte quello
terrestre aspetta di pagare e quindi li
fa scusi ma questa dall'unico pesce che
avevate fanno in realtà è che il proprio
a volte che non re a mangiare da noi
quindi approfittate e questo permette
nel futuro io vedo nella mia visione di
futuro della della finanza e
dell'economia e anche la possibilità di
separare l'utilità di una cosa dalla sua
immagine o dal senso di immagine che mi
dà abbia visto prima l'esempio del
tostapane ragazzo parla avrà inizio di
questo senso di piacere che si prova
nell'acquisto in realtà in realtà c'è un
problema di utilità del del bene deve
essere riconquistata perché se io riesco
a definire di più il valore dell'utilità
piuttosto che il valore dell'immagine di
un bene
probabilmente crea con beneficio per la
società perché riesca ancorarle in più
ai bisogni vieni piuttosto da quelli
fittizi
quindi la la moneta unica crea anche una
maniera di paragonarsi attraverso il
pianeta questo molto pil però ci sono
persone che ci stava pensando seriamente
a crearla giornate ma deve essere una
moneta globale su internet creata dal
basso perché sennò giovano funziona se
viene imposta dalle economie emergenti
non funziona l'ultima parola e soul come
soul search e salvo di ne anima in
inglese e soul searching perché in
realtà quello che abbiamo di fronte
di fronte oggi è una crisi d'identità
della finanza della società eccetera ma
anche anche l'opportunità è
un'opportunità per ricominciare
come dicevo durante oggi questa
chiacchierata cominciare a riconsiderare
quali sono i veri valori e le vere cose
su cui fare leva e quindi la finanza
deve ripartire in qualche maniera ad
arica per capire qual è il suo ruolo
nella del pianeta perché ne ho visto
negli eccessi della finanza avrà portato
alla speculazione hanno portato appunto
a a tantissimi problemi e oggi siamo a
questo bivio ben preciso e ora vi vorrei
fare un esempio di cosa vuol dire questa
cosa quando dico souls e che cosa vuol
dire anche cosa abbiamo da conquistare
vi faccio sentire 30 secondi perfetto di
un trader
nel dl dal pit pizze reb e la scatola
d'azione box che anno fa nelle
contrattazioni di wall street
un 3 dell'indice standard poor e il
disagio in cui egli ha prezzo
ok in questo giorno questo questo trader
che avete sentito la sua disperazione
in questo giorno era il 6 maggio del
2010 la borsa di wall street su indice
perse il 10 per cento in 20 minuti
cercano anche una cifra incredibile
quindi pensa il 10 per cento in 20
minuti e nessuno sa perché nessuno sa
cosa è successo quel giorno o forse sa
cos'è successo a un certo punto quando
l'indice ha rotto alcune barriere tipo
1100 mille sono partite le vendite
automatiche dei titoli e quindi la
macchina ha preso il sopravvento
sull'uomo sul sistema e quindi se andate
online cercate secs 6 maggio 2010 andata
a sentire i venti minuti di agonia di
questa persona oggi non posso farvi
sentire perché sennò è terrificante
perché la borsa perde il 10 per cento in
20 minuti mai visto prima
e tutti pensavamo che il mondo fosse
finito altro che mai ha cioè ero in
ufficio pensavamo che fosse veramente la
fine è però cosa succede subito dopo
l'indice di parte
ok ho voluto lasciare questa immagine
avete sentito il suo senso di sollievo
quanto mercato ha chiuso
poveraccio vedete il mercato ha perso il
10 per cento e poi quasi risalito agli
stessi livelli
ma questo scusate vado con armi acceso
questo è il crollo generato dalle
macchine e questa di partenza generata
dall uomo perché questa risalita
dall'alto l'hanno fatta questo thread e
tutti gli altri tre esempi di fatto
permette per ben tre anni di vita
per farlo fare e questo lo pensa però
bello questo è la la bella esperienza
in realtà questa l'aberrazione
l'aberrazione della finanza che di fatto
rende l'uomo le attività umane schiave e
delle macchine
qualcuno prima parlavamo di droni di
cloni di di uomo e macchina in realtà
questo qui è il pericolo che che abbiamo
corsi continuiamo a correre che di fatto
ci affidiamo sempre di più appunto alla
tecnologia e dimentichiamo il lato umano
a questo caso ce l'ha fatta però è la
bella immagine quello punto di una
piccola apocalisse visto che non
possiamo farla dell'apocalisse
oggi quindi da questo punto di vista
da questo punto di vista sono mail i
punti importanti e sono queste per un
futuro della finanza una finanza
sostenibile che pensano solamente in
termini finanziari ma anche in termini
sociali e di sostenibilità ambientale
che pensi a lungo termine lungo termine
vuol dire parafrasando a quello diceva
keynes che essere tutto nel lungo
periodo siamo tutti morti
però sono vivi i nostri nipoti quindi
bisogna pensare al loro credo